vamos a calcular otra integral de
superficie y he cambiado un poquito la
anotación en vez de escribir la
superficie como sigma mayúscula lo puse
como una s mayúscula y en vez de poner
de sigma minúscula la puse de ese ok
entonces pero esencialmente a una es una
integral de superficie de la función y
la superficie que nos interesa es esta
la superficie dada por los puntos que
satisfacen esta ecuación x massieu
cuadrada menos zeta igual a cero donde x
se mueve entre 0 y 1 y ya toma valores
entre 0 y 2 ok
esta esta puede que sea más directa que
la anterior o al menos eso espero y esto
es porque podemos expresar a z como
función de xy de es decir de aquí si la
zeta la pasamos del otro lado tendríamos
que zeta es igual a x
y cuadrada entonces se está
esencialmente es la función una función
que depende de dos variables y por lo
tanto la superficie que estamos pensando
es la gráfica de esta función entonces
vamos a ver cómo se vería esto digamos y
aquí pongo
el eje zeta
déjenme quizás hacerlo no tan grande
aquí está digamos este es el eje z vamos
a pintar también
el eje x y el eje y aquí está espero que
sea muy claro mi dibujo estoy haciendo
mi mejor esfuerzo y x estamos diciendo
que se mueve entre 0 y 1 entonces si
aquí anda el 0 acá puede andar el 1 y ya
se mueve entre 0 y 2 entonces por
ejemplo aquí puede estar el 1 y acá
puede estar el 2 por lo tanto en
realidad en la región sobre el plano xy
de la que estamos hablando pues es
esencialmente todos estos valores verdad
todos estos valores
es este rectángulo en donde nos estamos
moviendo es la región en donde está
definido xy ahora quién es la superficie
bueno eso tampoco es muy difícil de ver
vamos a hacerlo con mucho cuidado por
ejemplo qué pasa si x ya son 6 son 0
ambos entonces estos dos se hacen 0 y z
es cero entonces empezamos de este punto
de aquí y fíjense que si x es cero
entonces sólo nos movemos a lo largo del
eje y entonces si x es 0 nos queda que 7
es igual a ye cuadrada entonces
esencialmente lo que vemos en este plano
digamos el formado por el eje z y el eje
y en ese plano lo que vamos a ver es una
parábola es una parábola que aquí sí sí
aquí vale 2 entonces aquí está el 1 el 2
el 3 y el 4
vamos a ver una parábola más o menos
esta parábola eso es lo que estamos
viendo digamos proyectado en ese plano
eso es cuando x vale 0 ahora qué pasa si
es el que vale 0 entonces z es igual a x
eso nos dice que sobre este plano x z
digamos este muro que se genera con
estos dos ejes lo que vemos es una línea
nada más que bueno no es no es tal cual
la línea identidad porque la escala en
zeta la hice un poco más apretada pues
lo que vamos a ver aquí es más o menos
esta línea
esta línea recta ok digamos esta línea
recta se queda en el muro de la
izquierda formado por el eje z y equis y
ahora a partir del 1 que es lo que vemos
que hay que agregar la parábola verdad
es decir 'sí'
si x es igual a 1 tenemos la parábola
uno más de cuadrada entonces esto se
mueve de forma parabólica
nada más que por aquí tiene que subir
más verdad y aquí hacemos esta línea
entonces esta es la superficie de la que
estamos hablando déjenme la remarcó más
estos son los bordes esta es la
superficie de la que estamos hablando
este punto viene de este es decir el
punto 1,0 va a dar a este este viene de
acá bajito
y bueno más o menos ahí es claro que la
superficie de la que estamos hablando es
la gráfica de esta función es
esencialmente está ok ahora qué
significa realmente lo que estamos
haciendo integrar la función ye sobre
esta superficie bueno podemos
interpretarlo como que ya es una función
de densidad ok digamos que ya es la de
si la densidad de algún cuerpo de algún
fluido es la densidad de masa y lo
estamos restringiendo a nuestra
superficie entonces jeff por de ese y
por de ese es esencialmente la masa que
hay en un pequeño pedacito aquí digamos
ok de tamaño infinite decimos la la masa
que hay en ese pedacito entonces si nos
movemos a lo largo de la superficie
bueno a lo largo de ya digamos si nos
vamos moviendo hacia allá se va
volviendo cada mes cada vez más denso
entonces a lo mejor aquí la superficie
se ve muy densa y poco a poco va
perdiendo densidad correcto muy bien
entonces
ahora a realmente parametrizar esto ya
dijimos que ya habíamos visto que
podemos utilizar a xy como nuestros
mismos parámetros entonces voy a hacerlo
para que coincida con la anotación que
hemos utilizado que x puede ser nuestro
primer parámetro que puede ser el otro
parámetro b
iceta esencialmente está dado por un + b
cuadrada verdad aquí está dado entonces
nuestro vector de posición lo podemos
definir como r que depende de dos
parámetros es o en la primera coordenada
en la dirección del vector y más b en la
dirección del vector j más y más de
cuadrada en la dirección del vector acá
está es nuestro este es nuestro vector
de posición y sólo hay que decir que
está entre 0 y 1 y que b está entre 0 y
2 ahí lo voy a dejar en el próximo vídeo
vamos a plantear muy bien la integral ya
que tenemos esta
utilización